for the past month i've been following a
story that involves some of the biggest
names in rainbow six siege
who've all had their accounts hacked and
while personal information was leaked
and bikini body who's a huge siege
youtuber was even permanently banned for
a short time
this story really starts with a small
youtuber who is still
banned so what the hell happened well
let me break it down for you
all right guys we've been streaming over
at twitch.tv slash the score esports for
a little while now
and if you like what we do here on don't
at me you'll probably like what we do on
clouded which is our talk show
that airs every wednesday at 1 pm
eastern
myself keith dan and colin break down
the biggest stories from esports and
streaming
so make sure you follow the channel so
you know exactly when we go live
alright back to the story alright so
these hacks
have been happening over the past month
but they're not hacks in the sense that
somebody is using
software to cheat in siege basically
what's happening is that each account
the hacker has gotten into they've
managed to convince ubisoft support to
reset two-factor authentication
emails and passwords to something they
want effectively taking over the account
and locking out the original owner
and two-factor authentication is
supposed to act as an extra layer of
security making it harder for people who
aren't you
to get access to your account and it was
bikini body getting
permanently banned by ubisoft because of
this hack
that caused this whole situation to blow
up online and the other names we're
talking about are guys
like nvk king george pengu seth
kickstar and macy j if you know siege
you definitely know these guys and over
the last month or so they've all had
their accounts
hacked or at the very least [ __ ] with
and in the cases of kickstart and seth
they've both had personal information
leaked including phone
and credit card numbers but before we go
too deep into the big names let's go
back to the beginning where i
first heard about this story it all
starts with super maxie a small
australian siege youtuber the way he
explains it about a month ago he woke up
to people in his discord freaking out
in an email from ubisoft saying that
somebody had logged into his account
under a new device
in the uk and he basically says that's
impossible i live in australia and i've
never been to the uk and on top of that
when he logged into his uplay account to
try to play
siege he got met with a message that's
saying this account has been permanently
banned
but um yeah i get up and jump on
my computer and open up siege and sure
enough i've got that message that
i've been well first off i log on to
steam and it's like you've been
permanently banned from
rainbow six siege right and i'm like oh
damn what the hell so i jump on
and i get the band message and i'm just
like
sorry i don't freak out or anything like
that i'm like oh okay there's been a
mistake
he went back and forth with ubisoft's
support for a while but they basically
said
hey the decision is final nothing is
going to change here
and to this day almost a month later his
account
is still banned he took to reddit to
explain the situation and out of sheer
desperation
he even emailed the ceo of ubisoft yves
gilman to explain what happened
nothing worked super maxi believes that
his account was hacked
the security measures were reset emails
and passwords all
changed and ubisoft just doesn't believe
that it wasn't him
and so i emailed him and i was just like
please like you know i told him about
myself i really tried to like
personalize and be like you know look
you know as
a fellow lover of the game which i'm
sure you love the game that you've
created
you know i'm sure that you um are
passionate about this community and
everything like that
i'm not trying to start beef i'm not
trying to start a war with you
i just want my account back and that'll
be the end of it like that's literally
all i want and instead of emailing me
back
or anything like that um i just got an
extra line
in my next support response message
which was in response to your email to
yves
and then was just like nope we've we've
fully investigated it and we believe
that you cheated
for him having his account banned means
he's lost a main source of
income and on top of that a portion of
his community
now believes that he could be a cheater
now originally when i heard about this
story i thought it was a shitty one-off
an anomaly that ended with this guy
probably getting screwed
but if we jump ahead a few weeks this
same problem is now happening to some of
the gigantic names i mentioned
earlier pengu king george nbk macy j
seph all of their accounts have been
hacked in a similar way
now while i interviewed bikini for this
story and you'll be hearing a lot of his
perspective here
i did confirm with a lot of the other
people involved that what he describes
is pretty much the same thing that
happened with them
the way bikini explains it he went to
bed the night of his birthday
and everything was great uh i wake up
um check twitter uh and uh yes
ironic had sent me a message like uh he
had received a message on uplay from my
account
uh with a new profile picture and
everything and it said the n word to him
and he said like uh dude
have you been hacked and then he sent a
picture of macy's r6 tab he realized
that macy had had his name
changed as well uh so he realized that
you know it was another one of these
hacker waves because it wasn't the first
time that this guy had done this
uh a month ago pengu was the target and
bk
were hacked three times in a week i
believe
yeah um so the fact that this has been
going on for a month
and and nothing has happened around this
is crazy and i i think this one was the
worst
so yeah the next morning after talking
to his ironic bikini knew
immediately that something was wrong so
he did what most of us would do and he
checked his email
and he finds a message from ubisoft
saying that somebody had logged into his
account from a new device and that his
account was used to cheat
and therefore was permaban but remember
this dude was sleeping off his birthday
i think it's safe to say that he was
obviously hacked bikini even posted a
transcript of the hacker talking to
ubisoft support where he very nicely
asks them to reset the two-factor
authentication
and yeah they basically do that and
remember the whole point of a two-factor
authentication is to make sure that [ __ ]
like this
doesn't happen it's supposed to make it
very hard for people who aren't you
to access your account and when ubisoft
asked the hacker to provide a proof of
purchase receipt for assassin's creed
they gave them a poorly photoshopped
version that somehow worked
and asking for proof of purchase is
pretty routine it's an easy way for
support to prove that who they're
talking to
is the actual owner of the account other
ways they do this is maybe
asking when's the last time you logged
into the account or what's the credit
card number associated with the account
and remember this process of convincing
ubisoft support to turn off two-factor
authentication
isn't random it's happened to almost
every person in this story that i've
mentioned so far
hey uh your support ticket is gonna
close if you know
if you don't answer and i was like uh i
never opened a support ticket
hello so i went to check there and like
there it all was
like there's him basically like asking
to change
email of the account and and they wanted
to verify it and they verified it with
that
they wanted to verify with a receipt a
receipt that he
faked and it wasn't even you know anyone
could have seen that they were
completely different receipts
than the one i actually have on my
account uh and
but they still went through with it and
and yeah then he has to disable the 2fa
they disabled the 2fa and yeah
he just kept going and they just allowed
him to do everything they basically just
gave him my account
now bikini did say that once ubisoft
support realized what was going on
they worked quickly with him to fix the
situation and although they did give him
back his account it took a whole
24 hours for him to get on band and on
twitter there's a specific account that
many people in the r6 siege community
believe that the hacker is using
and on the timeline there's multiple
different r6 siege accounts that are
being offered in a
giveaway and according to bikini and
many others in the community one of
those accounts belongs to macy
j one of the biggest siege youtubers out
there we identified that it was macy's
because like the level was like 577. i
think mace is one of the few players
that are actually above 500
and it was identical to mace's actual r6
tab level
i dm this person asking about the
giveaway and how they acquired these
accounts
and as you can imagine they didn't admit
to anything
now thankfully bikini body's situation
ended in the best way possible
ubisoft gave him his account back and
they eventually unbanned him but imagine
this happened to a pro on game day their
account gets hacked and ubisoft
eventually bans them prior to a match
it would be a nightmare and
unfortunately what's happened to super
maxi is a reality that a lot of smaller
creators face
the big name pros and creators get their
problems fixed quickly because
it looks bad on developers like ubisoft
if they don't
while the small time creators get either
ignored or just
forgotten entirely and i reached out to
ubisoft support
asking about any potential fixes or what
the plan was
but they never got back to me in time
for publication but seeing how this same
problem happened to some of the biggest
names in siege weeks after it happened
to super maxi
it looks like ubisoft has a big problem
on their hands that
seems like it isn't going away anytime
soon
if if this happened to me i would not
handle it well
i i've never once been banned in siege
okay
cs go all right fair enough i don't play
a lot of siege
i've been banned a bunch in cs go but
like
if you want to see me toxic have this
situation happen to me
i would lose my [ __ ] mind it would
not be it would not be good